G what's your favorite memory of Wes  Craven I worked with him too my favorite  memory of Wes was  um  probably just the first time when I  auditioned for him for uh for red eye  like a long time ago he was just a very  very when you tell your kids to shut up  hey guys uh Michael needs to tell you  something shut your yappers  no I'll get it I'll get it I'll get it  um that and then I actually read for him  I actually auditioned for him again  and it was I forget what movie it was  for but my reps had sent me the script  and I wasn't supposed to have it and I  knew all this information and I started  talking to him about the character  and they actually  pulled me into the back of their office  and made me open my email and watched me  delete it oh my god wow after my  audition you can go back in your in the  folder and get anything yeah yeah